let's study how to preprocess the data
set for token classification
token classification regroups any task
that can be framed as labeling each word
or token in a sentence
like identifying the person's
organizations and locations for instance
for example
we'll use a coinal data set in which we
remove columns we won't use and rename
the other ones to get to a data set with
just two columns
words and labels
if you have your own data set for token
classification just make sure you clean
your data to get to the same point with
one column containing words as list of
strings and another containing labels as
integers spanning from 0 to a number of
labels -1
make sure you have your label name
stored somewhere here we get them for
the dataset features
so you are able to map the integers to
some real labels when inspecting your
data
here we're doing named entity
recognition
so labels are either o for words that do
not belong to any entity
log for location
per for person
org for organization and misc for
miscellaneous
each label has two versions the b labels
indicate a word that begins an entity
while the i labels indicate a word that
is inside an entity
the first step to preprocess our data is
to tokenize the words
this is very easy done with a tokenizer
we just have to tell it we have
pre-organized the data with the flag is
split into what's equal true
then comes the hard part since we have
added special tokens and each word may
have been split into several tokens our
labels won't match the tokens anymore
this is where the word ideas of fast
organizer provides come to the rescue
they match each token to what it belongs
to which allows us to map each token to
its label
we just have to make sure we change the
b label to the eye contour parts for
tokens that are inside but not at the
beginning of a word
the special tokens get a label of minus
100 which is how we tell the transformer
loss functions to ignore them when
computing the loss
the code is then pretty straightforward
we'll write a function that shifts the
label for tokens that are inside the
world that you can customize
and use it when generating the labels
for each token
once that function to create or labels
is written we can pre-process the wall
data set using the map function
with the option batch equal to we
unleash the speed of our fast organizers
the last problem comes when we need to
create a patch
unless you change the preprocessing
function to apply some fixed padding we
will get sentences of various lengths
which we need to pad to the same length
the value needs to be applied to the
inputs as well as the labels since we
should have one label per token
again -100 indicates the labels that
should be ignored for the loss
computation
this is all done for us by the data
collector for token classification which
you can use in python tensorflow
with all of this you are either ready to
send your data on this data collector to
the trainer or use the 2tf dataset
method and the fit method of your keras
model
you